I've spread my dreams under your feet
tread softly because you tread on my
dream right I'm in a single income
household and Jen and I just had our
second baby I think it's time for a
raise I can't give you a raise it's like
giving a raise to a drug addict my
child's like a drug problem you're fired
you're fired obviously oh you must be
McCreary oh wow you're fired
so coming back back who are you
I'm my I'm a new writer go sit down okay
could you sit down please I'll just use
that trash can it's kind of comfortable
better than sure everyone I came to tell
you this year is your last what they
can't replace you if everyone loves you
then none of you understand what is at
stake here
I am being replaced think about why the
show is bad and come up with ways to fix
it I wish I was a woman of color so I
could just get me Java while we talked
about this you can't say that I know
what everyone thinks of me but just
because I was lucky enough to get this
job doesn't mean I'm stupid enough to
listen what exactly is wrong with my
bits you're a little old sin a little
weight what can I do about that
I have some jokes with Milan I shouldn't
do this in an English accent should I
know what this is your show it's an
expression of who you are
how would you describe Molly she thought
I was the vibrant splash of color on the
gray canvas of our writing staff I mean
I need you okay
I need your pushiness and lack of
boundaries you love me
no I didn't say that I know I mean
Hatton knows where it's at you know I
didn't say it in any of those words
[Music]